là où ça bouge à caen sur le port au
pavillon pour découvrir une première
édition d'un festival qui s'appelle pas
le mac est ce c'est pas demain alors
palmas est un festival qui réunit des
artistes graphiques et les musiques
actuelles en fait au sein donc de toute
la presqu'île de caen à mondeville
là c'est le coeur du dispositif on peut
voir des expositions il ya une
bibliothèque des balades qui participent
les gens y viennent les balades en
partir de la maison du vélo puis samedi
et dimanche à 15 heures et puis sinon
oui ici les gens peuvent venir à partir
de 13 heures jusqu'à 19 heures jusqu'à
dimanche 17h alors là sur le plan bus
que c'est en toute la presse qui nous
sommes là bertrand et là on va aller
voir des oeuvres où il ya un regain son
ami par exemple où il ya les tht f
donc là une manuelle on est devant
quelle oeuvre eh bien on est devant les
tht f qui viennent de lyon et il y a
plusieurs oeuvres en fait sur la pire
presqu'île un petit peu plus loin il ya
nelio journaux la rue gaston amis via
small qui intervient quand tu finis les
débrancher voilà il y a aussi les
graphiques ce jury qui sont à la maison
du vélo et gambettes au portobello donc
il y en a quatre et pendant le festival
aussi des concerts tout à fait des
concerts
donc le festival palma côté musique ça
va se passer ou et ben ça se passe au
porto bel europe club juste en face avec
jésus christ fashion barbe et bantam
l'alliance il y aura aussi une soirée au
cargö ça me dit avec mansfield il ya et
stranded horse
et puis il ya des c koi dix concerts
sauvages c'est ça des concerts sauvages
c'est-à-dire que ça se passe en dehors
des salles de concert et et demain c'est
dans le dôme de la mairie avec céline
picorent les dimanches il y aura robert
le magnifique toutes les informations
sur le site festival pendant le festival
un quorum et puis il vous donne tous les
tous les documents les plantes tout ce
qu'il faut pour faire le petit parcours
sur la presqu'île je suis sûre persuadé
il va faire beau ce week-end on se fait
quelques petites idées de sorties pour
la semaine et une poche de big et puis
voilà oh oui
le groupe caennais corde à bretelle sera
en tournée autour de lisieux pour quatre
dates à partir de mardi
rendez-vous à ménil guillaume à
hauteville hermival les vaux et saint
germain de livet
une semaine de création
cinématographique avec le 5ème kino
kabaret internationale de caen s'est
organisée par les films du cartel les
tournages de film commence dès ce soir
les projections ce flou vie mercredi et
vendredi à l'université amphi la ville à
l'invitation du cinéma lux le célèbre
documentariste américain frederick
wiseman sera mardi à l'amphi daure à
caen pour présenter son 40e philippe in
jackson wright wiseman a posé sa caméra
de coeur d'un des quartiers les plus
cosmopolites de new york
concert pour fêter les dix ans du réseau
focus jazz en normandie avec l'
orchestre national de jazz et le trio
infernal momus en première partie
mercredi soir au cargö
alors je vous invite maintenant autignac
en histoire de buller
donc je vous présente pieds qu on chante
et illustrateur et dessinateur plutôt
dessinateur auteur de cette merveilleuse
bd dont les planches sont exposés aux
petits lieux parlez nous un peu de votre
univers mon univers de dessin c'est se
dessine plutôt réaliste enfin j'essaye
et puis les derniers albums que j'ai
fait c'est juste avant la seconde guerre
mondiale la montée du nazisme c'est une
histoire historico fantastique et donc
c'est vous qui présidé cette année
l'édition du festival de bd à hérouville
par et non un petit peu de cette édition
là c'est vous c'est moi j'ai cet honneur
est d'avoir illustrer la fiche mais
alors qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire
pendant ces deux jours ben pas mal de
choses en fait c'est un festival qui est
assez familial on y rencontre des
auteurs en dédicace on peut discuter
aussi il ya des endroits où justement
des personnes peuvent venir avec leur
projet bd pour rencontrer des auteurs et
se faire corriger
il y à des performances graphiques fait
part des auteurs ou bien les prendre et
sortir un peu de la dédicace où ils vont
pouvoir dessiner en direct devant des
gens il ya une expo forcément sur moi
donc au total 45 au tort que vous pouvez
découvrir le 2 et 3 avril à hérouville